box office victory is a tricky thing to
capture whether you're a bold new idea
was some heavy star power or the latest
installment of a reliable franchise
quite a few 2019 movies with big names
and big budgets have received painfully
disappointing thumbs downs from critics
and audiences alike and no genre seems
immune here are 2009 teens biggest
box-office bombs in spite of mostly
positive reviews missing link missed
pretty spectacularly at the box office
a Yeti named Susan voiced by Zach
Galifianakis is found in the Pacific
Northwest by Sir Lionel Frost
voiced by Hugh Jackman Susan frost and
frost old romantic partner Adelina
fortnight voiced by Zoe Saldana embark
on a quest to unite Susan with other
Yeti in the Himalayas while it got
thumbs ups from critics missing link
didn't just do badly it made history
according to the website cartoon brew
missing link had the lowest opening ever
for film released in more than 3,200
theaters with its opening weekend take a
five point eight million dollars it was
also the lowest grossing release for the
stop-motion animation studio Laika
whose first film 2009 s Coraline enjoyed
a worldwide gross of 75 point three
million dollars compared to missing
links sixteen point two million dollars
sir line have you ever wanted something
so bad it hurt inside like gas but
sadder
yka has taken modern animation and
creatively satisfying new directions in
the past but they may actually be the
problem
since Coraline each successive new movie
from the studio has performed worse than
its predecessor keeping this in mind and
paying attention to those few critics
who panned missing link paints the
picture of a studio that's lost its edge
here's hoping they can get it back
together for their next release in a
universe where dolls are tailor made for
specific children ugly bill is the
receptacle for the ones too strange to
survive the Institute to perfection
standards in ugly dolls one of the toys
dumped an ugly film named moxie voiced
by Kelly Clarkson leads her friends to
the outside world to find out what
exists beyond their town
sounds like an okay premise right
anthropomorphic dolls
singing plenty of laughs a good message
for kids that being different isn't bad
it's what makes you unique what could go
wrong according to the critics very
little went right ugly dolls may say
it's about celebrating difference but
critics thought it was just
another helping of the same old stuff
with a boring plot that couldn't even
get to the level of being interestingly
bland another common complaints is that
while we all know movies aimed at kids
work hard for the merchandise revenue
ugly dolls seemed to be doing nothing
but advertising its merch in this case a
toy line that launched back in 2001
parents seemed to pick up on all of this
and as a result ugly dolls pulled in a
worldwide gross of nineteen point seven
million dollars not even half its budget
of forty five million dollars the
delightful coming-of-age comedy
book-smart the directorial debut of
actress Olivia Wilde is exactly the kind
of film that modern audiences say they
want but that Hollywood just won't give
them it's not a superhero film a sci-fi
adventure or an adaptation of an
existing property it's smart funny and
is led by a pair of talented young women
in Kaitlin deburr and beanie Feldstein
comedic heavies including Lisa Kudrow
Jason Sudeikis and Will Forte stocked
it's supporting cast it even had the
seal of approval from critics who
absolutely loved the movie audiences
however could not have cared less
basically a popularity contest he's
useless sure the film opened to some
stiff competition Disney's live-action
Aladdin opened the same weekend John
wick chapter three Parabellum dropped
the weekend before an Avengers endgame
was still chugging along toward eventual
world domination book-smart wasn't
really aiming for the same audiences
though going for a crowd with a
preference for well-made thoughtful
original fare over big-budget tentpoles
the problem that crowd simply failed to
show up maybe because they're content to
wait for smaller more cerebral flicks to
show up on streaming services if this
describes you take note maybe you'd like
Hollywood to make more films like book
smarts you may want to see the ones they
do give us in the theatres it wasn't at
all clear whether audiences even wanted
another installment in the shaft series
which fielded three entries starring
Richard Roundtree is the legendary
Private Eye who had risk his neck for
his brother man in the 70s and was
revitalized with a 2000 entry starring
samuel l.jackson as the legendary PI's
nephew nearly 20 years later Jackson and
Roundtree returned for a
multi-generational team-up which also
included the talented Jessie tea uh sure
is JJ shaft the son of Jackson's
character rather than giving moviegoers
an updated take on the franchise however
chap 2019 went backwards in all the
worst possible ways
expand the film to be jaw-droppingly
regressive with misogynistic and
homophobic streaks each a mile wide it's
outdated aesthetic wasn't helped by a
flimsy predictable plot and a troubling
reliance on stereotypes that haven't
played well for decades shaft is a case
in which a film's failure can't be
chalked up to anything other than what's
right there on the surface the flick was
simply an awful borderline depressing
waste of time so bad that the studio new
line dumped the film straight to Netflix
internationally it failed to even make
back its meager 30 million dollar
budgets proving that contrary to a
rightfully widely held popular belief it
takes more than samuel l.jackson to make
an awesome profitable picture Terminator
dark fate seemingly had all of the
ingredients to successfully resurrect
the long floundering franchise the
return of James Cameron as a producer
the involvement of Deadpool director Tim
Miller Flynn - Hamilton saddling up once
again a Sarah Connor and a slew of
talented young actors spilling out the
cast ignoring the three increasingly
ridiculous installments that came after
Terminator 2 Judgment Day the flick even
garnered mostly positive reviews so how
did it become perhaps the biggest money
loser of the year
tuk-tuk fast who first there's no easy
answer but one thing seems certain dark
fate failed to garner any interest
whatsoever among younger moviegoers many
of whom weren't even born when
Terminator 2 became a cultural
phenomenon in 1991 it could very well be
that the older fans who loved that film
and its 1984 predecessor simply failed
to pass that love down to the new
generation whose familiarity with the
franchise mostly began and ended with
three critically reviled movies 2003
Terminator 3 rise in the machines 2009 s
Terminator Salvation and the relatively
recent Terminator Genisys from 2015 bad
dark fate completely ignored in any
event the aptly titled dark fate which
was intended to kick-start a new trilogy
will almost certainly end up being the
final nail in the coffin of the
franchise the filmmakers can at least
take solace in the fact that Terminator
went out on a high note but this time it
sure looks like he won't be back ok
sorry about that one we kind of had to
waiting decades to make a sequel to a
beloved film is always a tricky endeavor
just asked the filmmakers behind
Bladerunner 2049 a very good movie that
underperformed severely at the box
office
dr. sleep adapted from Stephen King's
2013 sequel to his classic novel The
Shining positioned itself as a
continuation of Stanley Kubrick's much
adored 1980 film version of the original
novel and while this certainly seems
like a surefire formula for box-office
gold the movies shockingly poor
performance Illustrated that decent
reviews aside audiences were simply
uninterested in picking up with an adult
Danny Torrance nearly four decades after
Kubrick's film hit screens even if he's
played by you and McGregor to be fair
dr. sleep debuted during a Veterans Day
weekend during which it seemed that
nobody could be bothered to go to the
movies at all but as was the case with
the Terminator dark faith it seemed that
younger audiences simply didn't give a
rip about a sequel to a movie that
probably came out before their parents
were even old enough to see it with
September's it Chapter two failing to
hit the heights of its 2017 predecessor
it could also be that the Stephen King
Renaissance is winding down adding up to
perhaps the biggest mid budget plop of
the year one thing can be said for the
director of the latest Charlie's Angels
reboot - Elizabeth Banks she got right
out in front of the movies failure in an
interview shortly before the flicks
released she gave her opinion that at
the film tanked the blame would be on
both guys who don't like female action
leads and the entire superhero genre
apparently even successful female focus
superhero films like Captain Marvel and
Wonder Woman according to banks where
parts of a quote male genre right before
the movie opened - a downright dismal
box office she doubled down saying that
nobody has complained about all the
spider-man movies that have hit the box
office in the past 20 years like say the
three Elizabeth Banks was in back in the
2000s of course that comparison
conveniently ignores the fact that
Spidey is a beloved cultural icon while
Charlie's Angels is mostly known as a
cheesy 70s television show which was
never terribly highly regarded despite
the 2019 films capable leads it seems
like moviegoers simply had no use for
another Charlie's Angels movie they are
not likely to get another one either as
the flicks poultry eight million dollar
opening weekend qualified it as a
candidate for one of the year's biggest
money losers Fox's x-men series wasn't
supposed to end this way Dark Phoenix
was supposed to be epic a proper
adaptation of one of the most iconic
storylines in all of Mar
comics history one that bands were ready
to give a second chance after it was
already botched pretty badly in 2006's
x-men The Last Stand since Disney
acquired boxes television and film
assets with their 2019 merger the x-men
seemed destined to enter the Marvel
Cinematic Universe at some point but box
could have given their series which ran
for two decades and twelve films the
kind of mind-bending send-off it
deserved so what went wrong it wasn't
just one thing the flicks third act
famously had to be extensively retooled
due to similarities to Captain Marvel
and much of the cast including star
sophie Turner
were rightly accused to phoning in their
lackluster performances by the critics
that lambasted the film and you couldn't
even do that
let me show you how Dark Phoenix was
supposed to be the final entry in a
franchise that have been producing
diminishing returns for years while
2014's
x-men Days of Future past successfully
traded in nostalgia by merging the older
and younger mutants 2016 x-men
apocalypse was far less inspired
annoying critics and underperforming at
the box office setting up Dark Phoenix
for an epic failure perhaps that the
film had simply been better it could
have avoided its fate but it was
unfortunately simply terrible what do
you get when you put Matthew McConaughey
and Snoop Dog in the same stoner comedy
apparently not money because the
beachbum racked up only 1.8 million
dollars on its opening weekend the
lowest opening gross of McConaughey's
career the film is based on writer
director Harmony Korine sex periences
filming spring breakers McConaughey
stars his stoner poet moon dog as he
wanders through a smoky life in the
Florida Keys which mostly amounts to
listening to a lot of Jimmy Buffett's
until tragedy strikes isla Fisher
co-stars as Moondogs wife Minnie who
finances her husband's shenanigans while
she has an affair with moon dogs friend
lingerie played by snoop dogg while
assessing numbers for the beach bums
opening weekend deadline made a point
suggesting the film's poor performance
might have more to do with demographics
than taste recalling that kourin's
previous film Spring Breakers enjoyed a
stronger opening the article points out
that film's cast including James Franco
Selena Gomez and Vanessa Hudgins had a
much stronger cast for a millennial
audience than one with the 50 year old
McConaughey and a rapper whose star
shone brightest in the 90s then again a
plot that's repetitive at fast and
depressing at its worst doesn't help
matters much either check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about famous flops are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one